yes the inauguration is happening today
it's happening serve during and after we
finish the show will have more detailed
commentary on Monday probably bad news
about executive orders that will have
been issued by president Trump by then I
do want to tell you how corrupt the
entire thing is Trump has been selling
access to cabinet members there's
countless pay-to-play events where you
can buy your way into an inauguration
dinner with mike pence you can buy your
way into dinner with cabinet members and
the cost for admission for the cabinet
dinners is part of a package that runs
between a hundred thousand and two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
donation to the Presidential Inaugural
committee dinner with Vice
president-elect Pence is open to both
donors and corporate underwriters at the
level of 500,000 to 1 million dollars
the more cash you give the more access
you receive and the invitation states
that only select cabinet officials
Whittle tend which prompted a bunch of
people to be concerned having to pay all
this money and I'm going to end up with
just like Betsy DeVos talking about
grizzly bears and guns I want tillerson
I want Rick Perry whatever and if your
reaction to this is everybody does it
it's not true the entire Obama
inauguration scene didn't promise
anybody access to cabinet members in
this way Trump's Obama's 2009
inauguration didn't accept contributions
from lobbyists it didn't accept
contributions from corporations personal
contributions were limited to 50
thousand dollars here we have some
donation levels that starts at five
hundred thousand dollars so we're
talking about something drastically
different also corporations are buying
access to the Trump administration there
are companies known to have contributed
to the Trump inauguration that have
received millions or in some cases
billions in taxpayer dollars in
subsidies and seven of these
corporations that are very involved in
pay-to-play and buying access to trump
and his cronies I'm sorry his cabinet
members are 80 Bank of America boeing
Chevron Deloitte JPMorgan Chase
UPS in exchange for inaugural
contributions they will be receiving
unprecedented not unprecedented but
unprecedented access to senior members
of Trump administration and of course we
have all these different companies AT&T
Bank of America Boeing they all have
made major contributions Boeing for
example reportedly contributed a million
bucks towards Donald Trump's
inauguration and they are replacing Air
Force One you'll remember Trump's tweet
about that they want to replace the
Lockheed Martin f-35 they are set to
receive in 2017 more than 800 21 million
dollars from federal government
contracts and I could go through the
entire list we are in a kleptocracy the
kleptocracy officially begins today
brace yourselves because it's going to
be bad and we'll be here with you making
sure that the bad deeds do not go
unreported today's episode is sponsored
in part by indochino indochino menswear
line is fantastic I went and worked with
Chris at the Boston indochino showroom
and chris took my measurements we went
through fabric we went through button
styles we went through lining colors and
designs and within four weeks i had a
custom-made suit which i now we're
regularly on the david pakman show and
there's two ways to shop with indochino
you can go to one of the showrooms they
have nine in north america like i
mentioned including one here in Boston
or you can go to indochino calm where
you enter your measurements the website
will explain to you what you're
measuring and how to take those
measurements you then pick from hundreds
of fabrics and patterns you can
customize everything from the lapel
there's a jacket lining and more and
then you get a great suit custom fit to
you in four weeks and this week david
pakman show viewers and listeners can
get any premium indochino suit this is
great for 389 @ indochino calm when you
enter the code Pakman at checkout that's
PA que ma n and it gets you 50 percent
off the regular
price for a custom made to measure
premium suit and of course shipping is
free once again indochino calm promo
code Pakman for any premium suit for 389
and free shipping you won't have to
worry about a badly fitting suit when it
is made to fit you specifically check it
out